how's it going rose and blue though my
name is beer bad and welcome to
Stefano's howls my own custom story is
was made by Connor kill games making
dude he's been working for this support
to week that's for though but whatever
two weeks so I really appreciate that
someone would take a lot of time and
effort and create a costume on you know
based on my experience with amnesia
that's really really awesome
I feel honored I feel like hey II so
it's really cool I can't wait to play
this Oh already began huh it already
starts doesn't it mr. chair yes you know
Scotty what oh [ __ ] am i safe though
okay let's read this you're not be
scared I will help you escape
Stefano's house but you must find me
first I hear him coming
hey Mazz hi who are you was it you Jesus
no no it wasn't me ha ha man ok but
where is the fauna we need to find some
fauna I guess oh wow
the drawers something seriously was
wrong with the drawers yay I got Lantern
tinderbox
I have ridership Ana's house it was a
massive for such a small statue I wonder
what his plan is actually I wanted that
too but I cheers if there actually is
something down there oh whatever
um I'm pull fist bump piggy are you pump
yeah umph umph umph umph yi yi
let's go let's go you and me in the
closet come here come here I'll show you
something no I don't want a pig it
seriously though focus big focus focus
that's all you [ __ ] okay okay are you
ready for this piggy
yeah I'm pump chiffon Oh let's find
Savannah well woohoo
hey okay it's impossible to be that bum
no now I'm pum pum pum
okay Beauty this way this way follow me
follow me everything will be all right
everything's gonna be all right
oh I am stefano hasta fada why did he
throw a bro at me
really I love it a step follow is a dice
doing everything isn't good at all of
everything every time I attacked you it
was because it's the father did it it
wasn't me I swear it was the banner you
need to get the father it's you're the
only one who can do it and I can't
really move so I'll stay here with
biggie okay
well what I would haha I think what the
heck that was really nasty that looks
really nice
okay
yes he's done a real little job
designing the room is beautiful it's
real careful real and beautiful okay
Vanya mice what are you doing here I
hate myself
what ha ha ha
Alexander in my painting leave and walk
okay let's meet Oh such attractions many
translations only personal a statue
chest strap this manual ensures that two
parts of the traps are required to make
this work a secret shelf and a chest
if the shelf is closed then the statue
is trap after a good night's sleep at
this house when I went into the dining
room I was met with a brow so far biggie
we all had breakfast together wow that
sounds it sounds amazing I can't believe
we hadn't breakfast together I wonder
how that would look like
meesa bono the bro having breakfast Oh
what the Jesus are you doing this
Jesus don't look at me like that Jesus
okay
let's go here oh hey sexy hahaha oh man
I'm in a game look at me I'm in a game
mom look back ha ha
credit picked a better picture though
but yeah I'll have to do Wow is Wow
Hey look at this that's on me that's
right that's right
it's only that photo not that okay my
balls are not that huge ah oh man uh no
there's a spider on my face huh what's
going on
ah God is not everywhere
what the [ __ ] okay i am i found mutton
mutton we found no way we found Martin
Martin what really you're a cutie the
monthly
okay I'll help you Martin no problem but
oh we can use this perfect let's go my
hybrid auto blue bar yeah that's good
Martin get him boy he was wearing a
Swedish he was saying you're bad words
[ __ ] hooker or something
ah I'm not sure if I want to go in there
Stefano you crazy [ __ ]
- bottle dear bar O'Reilly - portal new
bar
oh really oh really
Oh Oh what do you think about that cow
what do you think about that
cow
seriously though what do you think by
that
cow I was heading to bed I overheard my
friends in the room planning to do
something to me it could be contagious
in the future I think something went
wrong here
I think the penis monster was supposed
to come out just thought
yes the thought
i lo I only have one key it's perfect
it's beautiful really I love it
I don't love it I love it
okay let's go here Oh like this
yes the fauna where is it
I need Stefano how you seen Stefano no
of course I'm how lady hi all do it
alright oh look come on the king ha ha
are you kidding me thank the girl not me
oh it was proof rinette I'm [ __ ] net
man
Isis bad things what oh what the [ __ ]
that was like suicide why why the game
kill me I am to carry on apparently well
all this way really okay okay I guess
where's the final cartridge portal your
power
me too me too okay it's okay right now
let's go Monster is not here anymore at
least that's good okay
yes
yes yes there's nothing in here my cup
oh I mean come on
oh man
all right this is Dorian and it opens
doing the wrong way that's my party get
me two rare okay I'll get you to your
buddy
oh I asked everybody thank you very much
oh [ __ ] for you to be the pond always
harder what okay thanks buddy
thanks Martin Martin Martin Luther tell
ya I'm opting out of y'all are we not
Martin my den Martin
bola bola bing-bong Martin Martin
barrels
mouse bear right oh what the
I knew it [ __ ] knew it
Oh huh bounce stop doing that
hey Farrah rap-rap Sheriff Ram bells
bells ion do our [ __ ] okay
either toilet oh uh medieval luxuries ha
da ah Billy I crawled all this way to
tell ya it's the follow he's crazy man
it's the fun oh man you need to get him
you're in it touch my nipples do it once
I don't okay okay I'll just uh paddy
come on
like the IH okay what are you doing here
again mr. cow mister
haha that's
no I don't want to go there
okay
Oh
doesn't sound very good
is not sound very good
oh it's a gang bang with biggest piggy
did you gang my knee I'm home but you
know yeah oh hey man
but the fog is gone
okay thank you can you move the [ __ ] out
away I need the king okay I get it
you're a block oh hey stop stop okay
okay it's not cool okay I have a king
man
I don't trust you I don't trust you
either
trust any of you
so which way this way
I mean I got the key but there's no
other oh that we got column needed
there we go
okay
ah [ __ ] getting me out of the hog
using the collet Oh broke him out of the
club that was oh come on he was totally
hiding in the garlic where am I
not a new barrels
bro
really though that ass it's so fluffy
so [ __ ] sweet
okay
that was [ __ ] cheap oh oh man I hope
it's not still there
it's gotten yeah
and there's the king I wonder how the
[ __ ] I was supposed to pick up that one
but yeah it's good
all is well all is swell
something here I know it I don't trust
you at all right okay what is this where
is the fauna a drunk bastard I hate him
no I love Stefano but he's doing all
these kind of things I don't know
ah
Stefano what are you doing here I love
pity you need to save me I don't know
what's going on oh man
alright I'll get you Stefano I swear
I'll get you okay breathing you can do
it huh
ah
exploding closets
not very good for my ha
all right it's all this what is all this
Oh
okay hey lovey hey man special edition
bro
don't you like me like this I've been
dieting you know I've been on a special
diet for a couple of weeks and this is
what happened
there's a bunch of yes I supposed to
find something don't I'm I have to check
all the closet I really don't want to
check all the closet
ah
there's so many yoga no there's
impossible Wow
they make a lot of noise something
the funnel
I'm uh supposed to do
why what tell me all your secrets now
Bravo no I'm not not doing this fun
it can't be I have to check all of those
it's impossible really though and I only
gave him this hat I shouldn't have this
anymore
Martin Martin Randa there we go is a
huge ascii on top of a bunny I am a
bunny how older oh come on you're coming
with me
I don't have Stefano I need something I
need something at someone I'm a bunny
yes I am you like my bunny son okay
let's just a huge house key
come on bunny them don't thumb block me
Thank You bunny now new adventures
what's going on here
happy scare day we decided to all get
together and scare your friends before
you left look up and you will see us
yeah oh my buddy we got a bro hey bro
and we got you mutton
Hey